dans une heure le spectacle va commencer
pour le moment fredo douchez responsable
du cirque s'occupe des derniers
préparatifs et des dernières
vérifications autour de la piste et du
chapiteau à 34 ans fredo a toujours
baigné dans le monde du cirque
aujourd'hui il est à la tête de la
compagnie à bata douche est composé de
30 personnes je suis né sur les routes
mon père mon grand père mon arrière
grand père depuis huit générations avec
mes enfants nous faisons du cirque et
nous renouvelons de spectacles tous les
ans car nous faisons souvent deux fois
les mêmes communes malgré qu'on voyage
sur toute la france et l europe mais on
change de spectacle comme tous les ans
le cirque si on n'est pas passionné on
ne le fait pas parce que c'est quand
même c'est comme un fermier on n'a pas
en a pas deux jours à nous on est
toujours sur notre lieu de travail c'est
tout neuf le cirque
j'adore aussi bien la mécanique que le
spectacle que ce soit au niveau des
lumières que non de faire des numéros en
piste d'être contact du public j'adore
ça et le cirque comme je disais à
l'instant c'est c'est vraiment cette
polyvalent quoi on peut être aujourd'hui
sur la route en train de conduire un
véhicule le lendemain on peut être avec
avec karine est en train de soigner un
animal beaucoup de personnes patientent
devant le chapiteau ils sont venus
découvrir les numéros un spectacle mené
par fredo le monsieur loyal depuis près
de dix ans c'est lui qui met tous les
spectacles en scène qui voit il n'y a
pas deux il n'ya pas de temps mort on va
dire et là où il ya un temps mort c'est
justement là où lui avec le clown ni va
combler cet endroit pour pas que lui tu
décroches au spectacle c'est moi qui a
la plus grande gueule on va dire et puis
cas mieux mieux être au contact fin
j'aime le plus au contact du public
et puis du coup comme j'ai passé un peu
la main j'étais exhausteurs avant j'ai
passé la main à mon jeune frère de will
fall et je me retrouvais un domaine et
je me suis mis à a commencé à être le
présentateur tout doucement je prends de
l'âge et puis je me rends compte que si
j'attends trop je pourrai plus en plus
vous avez vu tout à l'heure je fais
équilibrisme et je voudrais encore
changer mon numéro
mais j'aimerais bien redonner la main
qu'un autre le micro on va dire il
refaire des numéros en plus plus que
la famille un élément important dans le
monde du cirque dans cette compagnie le
frère michael douchez s'occupe des
animaux
il est comme moi et des passionnés ce
que je pense c'est que j'espère
continuer comme ça et puis qu'on va
évoluer dans ce milieu à pour moi on est
vraiment complémentaire 1 comme note
donc on est vraiment content d'être
ensemble à la fin du spectacle la
pression retombe tout s'est bien passé
à la fin du spectacle je vais d'abord
allé me changer voir si toute l'équipe a
bien rangé le matériel
et puis boire une bonne tasse de café
pour me réchauffer puisque fait froid
dehors
le repos est de courte durée il reste
encore du travail pour cette famille qui
parcourt les routes de france